[Musique]
David cou bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle serw on aurait voulu avoir
votre vision de la justice de la
démocratie et de l'affaire carviel je
vais mettre une précaution oratoire
spécialement aujourd'hui parce que tu es
mon avocat donc comme tu es mon avocat
je ne vais pas pouvoir te vous voyer
qu'est-ce que tu peux je vais avoir du
mal aussi qu'est-ce que tu peux me dire
sur la justice en France on en est où là
euh vu de chez moi vu de là où je me
trouve mais tu trouveras des gens qui
t'expliqueront que que tout ça de la
fouaise euh on est dans une situation
qui est particulièrement préoccupante
parce que
euh la justice est à divers égards tenu
tenu comment par qui oh ben on va on va
se le dire pendant une heure je
j'imagine
euh
tenue et elle est totalement
dysfonctionnelle elle ne fonctionne pas
alors non il faut nuancer un peu le
propos un dossier de de Monsieur machin
contre madame truc
tout va bien se passer et et le droit
dira qui a raison et qui a tort mais
quand il y a des dossiers qui sont dit
signaler c'est avec un signalement
particulier et tu sais très bien à quel
type de dossier je fais référence
c'estàd quand tu as un candidat à la
présidentiel un ancien président de la
République un financier Deol un
industriel un peu charpenté une
institution bancaire par
exemple là il y a une sorte
de Pact de place euh qui se met en en
œuvre qui se met en route de manière
tout à fait silencieuse et euh chacun
sait ce qu'il a à faire euh pour planter
le dossier c'est la justice des copains
ouais ouais c'est comme ça que je l'ai
qualifié il y a pas euh il y a pas très
longtemps c'est c'est une justice entre
potes c'est une justice qui se passe
dans le noir quelles sont les
conséquences pour le Pékin lambda bah le
Pékin lambda euh lorsqu'il est pris dans
cette NAS dans cette tu vois dans ce
dans ce filet médiatico-judiciaire
euh et qu'il importe qu'il qu'il soit
condamné bien il l'est au mépris des
droits de sa défense au mépris du droit
tout
court l'indépendance des juges n'est
n'est pas du tout opérationnelle je veux
dire je crois pas tu sais Sky qu'on
puisse poser la question de manière si
générale parce que tu as toujours de
très bonnes surprises et c'est ce qui
fait que que notamment moi je continue
de de de faire ce travail euh tu as
toujours des résistants il est important
ce mot résistant et euh et et il y en a
chez les juges qu'il soient qu'ils
appartiennent à à l'instruction ou ou au
siège c'està-dire à l'autorité de de tu
vois au diverses autorités qui existent
dans l'ordre judiciaire je sais pas si
on ira là-dessus ou pas tu tu tu me
diras ce que tu veux qu'on qu'on qu'on
aborde mais
euh en gros pour pour essayer de résumer
dans ces dossiers il y a des réseaux qui
sont à l'œuvre alors toutite quel quel
type de réseau je vais t'expliquer ça
alors tout de suite il faut dire un mot
parce que cette phrase je pense qu'on
est ici typiquement dans un endroit où
où où ce propos ne ne choquera pas mais
mais cette phrase quand elle est émise
quand elle est verbalisé tout de suite
tu as une espèce de levée de bouclier où
on te dit ah la théorie du
complot non la relation des faits au
sens relater les fait au sens observer
ce qui se passe factuellement et le
décrire
donc ces réseau ils sont de de de divers
ordres c'est-à-dire il y a des des
sortes de fraternité il y a des sortes
de quand tu dis fraternité tu parles de
la franc-maçonnerie notamment notamment
alors j'ai pas c'est pas mon cheval de
bataille la la franc-maçonnerie et puis
en théorie quand je regarde comment le
comment le machin fonctionne c'est
plutôt joli tu vois mais on ne vit pas
dans la théorie on vit dans la pratique
et en ce qui me concerne alors tu reçois
des gens qui font tout un tas de boulot
différents en ce qui me concerne dans la
théorie judiciaire voilà et donc quand
dans un certain nombre de dossier tu
constates que ton adversaire tout comme
le procureur
tout comme son avocat peuvent être
maçon ça ne signe pas qu'il y a une
magouille mais tu peux pas ne pas le
voir donc ça peut être ça ça peut être
des copineries en tout genre il y a des
clubs d'élégant alors nous on n'est pas
sur ce dossier là en tout cas on n'est
pas dans le camp des élégants on est on
est dans le camp des des des turbulents
tu vois nous nous turbulons voilà du moi
c'est comme ça qui vous qualifie oui
bien sûr parce que ils sont dans une
espèce de process un peu de procédé un
peu incantatoire où à force de répéter
la mme connerie 200 fois sur C médias
choisis ils se mettent eux même à
croire aux salades qu'ils inventent tu
vois c'est ça qu'ils font c'est même et
c'est même comme ça qu'on arrive à à à
les décrypter parce que le le le
processus pour pour décrypter c'est un
processus qui est très important parce
qu'on est dans une dynamique là dans ce
type de dossier je te parle notamment de
l'affaire dit Kerviel et on peut en
évoquer un certain nombre d'autres mais
on est dans un processus où pour que le
message ne passe pas il est important
pour pour ces gens et on met des noms
sur les gens au moment où tu le veux he
tout va bien parce que je suis pas dans
un propos général tu vois on peut
rentrer en sur le sujet oui on va le
faire on est les avocats de Société
Générale par exemple que jeanveille
jean- renard tu vois ce sont des ce sont
des gens
qui fabriquent une espèce de vérité
médiatique au terme de laquelle il nous
accuse quasi systématiquement de ce
qu'ils sont eux des exemples bah par
exemple moi je serai un avocat
médiatique alors que mon activité soit
médiatique à à divers égards c'est le
cas mais tu es bien placé pour le savoir
mais parce que les médias s'intéressent
à ça et qu'il nous sollicite et tu sais
très bien pour me connaître bien que je
passe plus de temps à refuser des
interviews qu'à en faire quand on y va
c'est que quelque chose a déraillé là il
renverse un peu l'équation en disant
les cubi font ça parce qu'ils veulent se
médiatiser mais nous on vend pas des des
t-shirts on vend pas des livres on fait
la promotion de rien tu comprends
peut-être qu'il te disent ça parce que
ils ont l'impression que tu souhaites
retourner l'opinion publique contre eux
alors moi moi je je ne souhaite pas
retourner l'opinion publique parce que
si je retournais l'opinion publique elle
serait des facto contre nous parce que
l'opinion publique est déjà contre
contre
eux moi je suis pas là pour ça moi je
suis là pour te dire une chose qui est
très simple c'est que je ne ressens nul
besoin de les calomnier de les diffamer
de les dénigrer de les ridiculiser
puisqu'il nous suffit là où nous en
sommes rendus de les décrire ainsi
qu'ils sont qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait là
sur ce dossier tu veux dire ils ont
inventé une fable qui a servi à renommer
un certain nombre de pertes financières
comment ils l'ont formulé colossal en
disant que que que Jérôme kviel était un
terroriste en disant qu'il était en
fuite en disant que c'était un ancien
membre des services de contrôle en
disant que c'était un joueur en disant
qu'il était suicidaire en disant que
céit un pervers manipulateur en en
faisant de moi une sorte d'animateur
télé raté ou un acteur de séries Z qui
se qui se voyait à Hollywood ou ou ou ou
ailleurs la réalité du sujet c'est pas
celle-là c'est que Jérôme kviel am merdé
dans les proportions qu'on sait et qu'il
admet et qu'il admet depuis le premier
jour de l'affaire oui il a pris des
positions spéculatives qui sont en volum
en nominal totalement hors norme mais
contrôler par ces hiérarchie mais
naturellement tu sais c'est un c'est un
milieu où quand beaucoup de traders nous
disent ça parce que on parle avec
beaucoup de gens du marché financier on
te dit ils ont une phrase qui les fait
marrer je comprends parce qu'elle est
marrante qui est quand tu tiens un book
un book de trading un portefeuille de
trading et que tu vas pisser ton
supérieur hiérarchique vient contrôler
ce que tu as fait pour voir tes Paes tes
positions spéculativ donc si tu veux
aller expliquer
que Jérôme gerviel a fait tout
cela seul et sans que personne ne l'ai
vu ça ce sont des fouthaises donc la
question après c'est quel intérêt c la
sert que de que de que de tricoter de T
fouthaises alors il y a bien il y a bien
quand même des alertes sur une salle des
marchés jérô carviel il a pas pu quand
même créer une salle de marché virtuelle
pour passer ses ordres comment comment
la Société Générale a justifié le fait
de ne pas voir les choses ah non non
jeune homme atttion attention Société
générale n'a rien à justifier parce que
c'est Société Générale et donc je vous
prierai de retirer cette question que je
trouve très insultante pour cette
honorable banque non non Société
générale ne justifie rien ces avocats ne
justifient rien parce que tu sais il y a
deux codes pénaux il y a le code
pénal pour les gens qui te regardent
c'est-à-dire les les les Mister and Mrs
nobody donc là il est épé il est
technique il nécessite de de payer des
avocats pour savoir comment comment
mouvementer tout ça et puis il y a un
code pénal qui est beaucoup plus fin qui
est de la justice entre entre
potes donc c'est chiant ce que je dis et
je je je sais que ça te plaît pas mais
mais c'est comme ça par exemple quand
quelqu'un pourra m'expliquer pourquoi un
ministre chargé de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale et lui-même un évadé
fiscal ne fait pas un jour un jour de
détention provisoire quand on envoie en
prison un citoyen comme Jérôme kviel qui
ne s'est pas enrichi qui n'a pas tenté
de le faire il ne s'est pas enrichi
parce qu'il a loupé il ne s'est pas
enrichi parce qu'il n'a pas tenté de le
faire et qu'on l'envoie en prison pour 5
ans dans trois fermes alors il se trouve
que nous avons obtenu l'aménagement de
sa peine au bout de de 3 mois mais même
3 mois 3 tout là tu te r puis au moment
où tu rentres en prison tu sais pas que
ça va durer 3
mois Com Com comment on va revenir sur
sur Jérôme je voudrais je voudrais qu'on
aborde l'aspect judiciaire comment
comment le le le fonctionnaire t'aborde
comment il se comporte par rapport au
dossier est-ce que c'est le
fonctionnaire dévoué à faire respecter
la loi ou tu sens que bah il en a rien à
faire il a reçu des consignes bah là
encore Sky tu peux
pas poser l'équation comme ça parce
qu'elle est elle est trop pardon mais
elle elle est trop maniquéenne il n'y a
pas un fonctionnaire il y a une
multitude de fonctionnaires donc en gros
pour euh répondre un peu mainstream euh
tout le haut du panier est contre nous
le gratin ouais bien sûr et puis en
dessous les résistant les plus petits tu
vois c'estd ceux sur la gueule desquel
on appuie
euh pour mettre en place des schémas qui
sont uniques qui ne respectent pas le
droit et bien de temps en temps la grâce
fait que cela nous rallie la grâce ou ou
peut-être le fait qu'ils soi aussi
perturbés par leur propre valeur
l'engagement de la grâce la grâce mais
c'est ça la grâce la grâce c'est quand
euh moi qui suis ton subordonné
j'entends un ordre qui est illégal et
que j'ai là deux choix tu vois comme
quand tu arrives à l'oreille d'un y soit
tu pars à gauche soit tu pars à droite
mais ça ne se rejoindra plus jamais et
donc là il y a des gens qui écrasent le
coup et qui font ce qu'on leur demande
de faire ceux-là sont promus ils sont
choyés ils sont chouchoutés et tu vois
et tout va bien et puis il y en a
d'autres s'appelle des lanceurs d'alerte
qui est un sujet que que vous
connaissez est-ce est-ce que est-ce que
dans le dossier carviel tu as tu as eu
des des lanceurs d'alerte côté
judiciaire bien sûr queles sont été
comment ça s'est formulé comment ça a
été réfléchi ou c'était simplement
instinctif ou c'était alors je je ne
suis pas le mieux placé parce que je ne
suis pas moi un lanceur d'alerte je suis
le le le le défenseur de de Jérôme kviel
son avocat
mais le commandant natthalie Leroi qui
est un officier de police judiciaire qui
appartient au corps de la brigade
financière la très prestigieuse brigade
financière Château des
Rentiers cette personne est la policière
qui est en charge de l'enquête dès le
dépôt de plainte de Société Générale en
janvier 2008 et donc elle va être la
cheville ouvrière de tout le
dossier donc tu tu vois comment ça se
passe une une instance pénale tu as un
dépôt de plainte ou une autosaisine par
le ministère public c'est-à-dire le
procureur de la République ensuite de
cela tu as une enquête prélim ou une
instruction
ou les deux chronologiquement et puis là
tu as des opérateurs police qui vont
travailler en aide du magistrat
instructeur c'est-à-dire du jus
d'instruction qui en l'occurrence était
Renault van runbeck et sur ces sujets je
crois qu'il est important de dire quel
sont les noms des gens qui ont été
impliqués parce que si je te demande qui
a condamné SNEC tu ne sais pas me
répondre moi non plus d'ailleurs si je
te demande qui a condamné de drefus on
ne sait pas répondre à ça parce qu'on
dit c'est l'institution ça euh
c'était une vision du judiciaire que je
qualifierais si tu me permets de alapa
là maintenant il est important que les
actions de tel ou tel fonctionnaire les
[Musique]
engagent moi j'aime bien et tu sais par
exemple notre relation à nous deux est
basé là-dessus tes mots t'engagent mes
mots m'engagent une parole est une
parole oui oui mais c'est évident tu
sais nous on est dans le clan des bons
cons moi j'ai prêté un serment euh je
colle à mon serment je ne dévis pas je
ne tangente pas et j'ai r gviel c'est la
même chose c'est je je le dis souvent
marrant quand je suis avec lui non mais
toi tu as un Breton parce que Breton
c'est pas pareil si tu veux c'est c'est
des en tout cas lui tu vois ça dévie pas
ça recule pas ça plie pas bon mais ces
gens-là
euh lanceur d'alerte ils sont face à des
choix qui sont des choix euh
euh très violent parce que tu as le
choix entre le confort de faire ce qu'on
te dit de faire et il y a une espèce de
de confort un peu paternaliste là-dedans
qui est je suis ton supérieur je te
demande de faire ça bon ben une
soumission consenti tout est très simple
oui et puis tu sais ce que je pense de
ça je crois et puis il y a un autre
choix qui est qui est qui est celui de
raller le camp de
l'honneur et c'est ce qu'a fait cette
policière c'està-dire que moi quand je
suis rentré dans le dossier non pas en
janvier 2009 quand je je je m'occupais
des de de des intérêts de Jérôme kvier à
l'endroit de la presse et uniquement en
droit de la presse mais en mars 2012
lorsque j'ai pris la la tête de de de sa
défense pénale côté d'autres avocats de
mon cabinet comme tu
sais j'ai dit à Jérôme on va commencer
par rencontrer tous tes adversaires et
il a nommé cette flic natthalie leroie
et donc moi je j'ai plongé dans le
dossier et je voyais que je sais pas je
peut-être dire une bêtise mais 90 à 95 %
des actes de la procédure en enquête
donc pendant inststruction était siglé à
nom elle faisait les confrontations les
perquisitions elle signait les PV
d'audition procèb d'audition tu vois bon
donc elle était très très présente sur
le sujet je suis allé la voir et je me
suis présenté elle m'a reçu très
froidement c'est une personne qui
est écoute moi jeen savais rien en tout
cas à ce momentl mais je je le postulais
en tout cas tu vois et je lui dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe si vous vous êtes
planté je te fais le truc en très résumé
m'a dit je ne me suis pas planté
ma question c'est pas ça c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe si vous êtes planté je ne
comprends pas la question tu vois c très
froid parce que j'incarnais l'avocat
Kiel c'était
pas spécialement envie de me voir pu moi
plus j'is pas spécialement envie de
voirut pas le droit elle droit de te
voiroui complètement elle convoqu mon
client dans le cadre des plaines que
nous avions déposé donc je suis allé la
saluer
et et puis elle m'a
dit m'a demandé de préciser ma question
je dis est-ce que vous ferez le job si
vous vous êtes planté où est-ce que vous
allez couvrir votre erreur elle m'a
répondu je ferai mon travail et à partir
de là avec jérô carviel on a décidé de
drainer nos nouveaux témoins vers elle
les questionnement qui étaient des
questionnements liés au dossier on a
décidé de d'envoyer ça vers elle parce
que on collaborait avec la brigade
financière puisque nous avions déposé
des plaintes et qu'elle enquêtait sur
les plaintes que nous avions déposé fort
logiquement puisqu'elle avait fait tout
le premier volet du dossier et puis
petit à petit dans les procès verbaux
d'audition euh et dans les diligences
dont elle était le l'auteur on on se
rendait compte que ça tournait tu vois
que sa vision était en train de euh
d'évoluer et donc j'ai pris le risque de
demander au doyen des juges
d'instruction Roger Leloir qui instruit
les trois plaintes enfin deux des trois
plaintes pardon que nous avons déposé
contre Société Générale faux et usage et
escro au jugement subordnation témoin
est encore ailleurs
euh je fais cette demande d'acte auprès
du doyen des juges d'instruction lui
demandant de la recevoir enfin de la
convoquer pour l'auditionner sous
serment et de lui poser certain nombre
de questions neuf de mémoire et là elle
nous dit sur procèsverbal qu'elle a la
conviction d'avoir été manipulé par
Société Générale elle nous dit sur
procèsverbal que tout au début de
l'affire elle était convaincue de la
culpabilité de kervviel et
qu'aujourd'hui elle est convaincue de
son innocence elle nous dit sur procès
verbal qu'elle est convaincue que la
hiérarchie de Jérôme kviel était au
courant de ses actions donc tu vois ce
n'est pas neutre et là elle devient un
lanceur d'alerte et là elle fait œuvre
de courage tu vois c'est des trucs bon
tu tu tu tu me sais pas spécialement
douiller mais c'est des trucs à chialer
de beauté parce que tu tu es en face de
quelqu'un qui a été un ennemi
objectif dont toutes les diligences
servaient à amener le dossier là où sa
vision l'a commandé de l'amener elle en
est où là maintenant elle a été
placardisée elle a été envoyée à Cayenne
alors écoute il ne me revient pas de
répondre précisément sur le sur le sujet
parce que ça touche d'autres intérêts et
je ne suis pas son avocat
euh mais euh je peux te dire qu'elle a
été lâchée par sa hiérarchie et je peux
te dire également que elle subit en tout
cas je ne sais pas si elle subit là mais
elle a subi le traitement que nos
honorables institutions réservent à
l'accoutumer au lanceurs d'alerte et
c'est dans ce contexte là qu'elle a pris
la
décision d'aller parler avec son
homologue au parquet c'està-dire
l'autorité de pour ensite la section
financière du parquet de Paris qui est
censé être notre avocat à tous mais dans
ce dossier c'est pas comme ça que ça
s'est passé ils sont comportés comme
étant les avocats de la Société Générale
voilà l'avocat général qui devient
l'avocat général de la Société générale
c'est des mod dur tu vois le truc bah
oui mais c'est des m dur mais que
j'assumerai tu sais bien ça et et elle a
enregistré la conversation qu'elles ont
eu et alors que cette procureur de la
République parlait en toute
liberté alors que le commandant Nathalie
Leroi aucun moment ne la lance ne la
piège en lui posant des questions en
disant vous avez vu bon et bien euh
cette procureur confirme ce que dit
cette policière c'est-à-dire que le
dossier a é entièrement manipulé elle
donne des noms elle donne des dates
elle implique des gens elle dit qu'elle
a eu à signer des choses qu'elle n'avait
pas la volonté de signer elle évoque des
pressions elle évoque des
manipulations tu vois donc on est dans
un sujet qui est euh très aigu là sur
fonctionnement institutionnel gravissime
évidemment et
euh Nathalie Leroi commandant de police
on avait parlé à sa hiérarchie on avait
parlé au parquet à déposé je
l'expliquais devant le doyen des juges
d'instruction a fait état de cela à son
ministère de tutelle c'est-à-dire le
ministère de
l'Intérieur et rien ne s'est passé à
part le fait qu'elle s'est fait brer
comme un lanceur d'alerte donc là elle a
pris la décision de m'adresser euh le
contenu de ces enregistrement en
m'indiiquant que j'en étais
l'unique dépositaire l'unique détenteur
en me disant qu'elle avait tout tenté
pour que la justice passe sereinement et
que ce n'est pas ça qui se passait et
donc moi j'ai été confronté à ce
moment-là à un choix qui consistait soit
dans le fait de de dire bien écoutez
vous avez enregistré à son insu une
procureur de la
République je ne peux pas utiliser cet
élément ou un autre choix le fameux y
dont je te parlais
était je suis en charge de la défense de
Jérôme kviel je suis avocat à la cour
d'appel de Paris j'ai prêté un serment
ce serment doit servir la défense et on
doit placer la défense audessus de tout
donc j'ai pris le
l'option d'utiliser ces enregistrements
et de les rendre publiques donc il y a
très peu du contenu des enregistrements
qui qui a été rendu public à date parce
que il y a une démarche stratégique il
faut pas se le cacher qui passe qui
croise une démarche médiatique alors ça
ça suragace mes adversaires parce qu'ils
disent oui alors il Médiatis et cetera
mais évidemment qu'on médiatise parce
que leurs exploits crapoteux ça se passe
où ça se passe pas à nuit debout au vu
et auudessus de tout le monde àêpu pas
ça qui se passe ça se passe dans des
cabinets feutrés c'est dans le noir donc
notre boulot c'est de les flasher
ensuite on fait développer les photos et
on regarde qui a la main dans la culotte
de
qui tu vois c'est ça c'est ça le sujet
et tu sais qui m'a demandé ces
enregistrements sapin non personne
personne t'a demandé les enregistrements
sû que non
personne personne par qu'il y a une
espèce de stratégie de l'ron tu vois
espèce de gros machin qu'on met
là-dessus une espèce de couvercle une
bonne procédure billon ou donc voilà
tout ça tout ça est assez intéressant
dans une vie d'homme et dans une vie
d'avocat c'est c'est l'affaire de ta
vie j'espère pas pour l'instant c'est
l'affaire de ta vie toi en tant qu'homme
avec tes valeurs quand tu te retrouves
face à la Société Générale qui veut
couler quelqu'un tu as des valeurs tu te
qualifies entre nous d'anarchiste ça
veut dire quoi anarchiste pour
toi euh tu veux dire tu testes ma
connaissance sur ce qui'est l'anarchie
ou tu veux dire ce que ça veut dire pour
moi ouais euh écoute je me suis qualifié
il y a longtemps de tu votes bah non non
mais pour qui je voteraiis pour qui
veux-tu que je vote euh non non je ne
vote pas non non bien sûr que non je ne
vote pas et j'engage ceux qui te
regardent à cesser de le faire euh tu
vois enfin ou alors à voter pour la
petite souris euh c'est-à-dire pour
quelque chose qui existe plus que
l'équité républicaine euh je je suis
trop
républicain pour ne pas être anarchiste
je sais pas si tu comprends ça euh je
j'ai j'ai une j'ai une une une passion
euh
euh lourde euh forte pour la République
et ce qui en est fait
aujourd'hui
par de douzaines de de de
connards qui se sont mis sur les
fauteuils de de nos gouvernants me
dégoûte au plus haut point au plus haut
point et je les fréquente beaucoup là
encore je je ne souhaite pas que tu
entendes dans mon
propos que je fais une espèce de machin
tous pourri parce que qui a des
politiques comme Mélenchon comme Eva
jolie comme George féneec tu vois donc
la salle ouais ouais que j'ai que j'ai
rencontré qui est qui est qui
est un vrai mec engagé Yan Galu qui est
un député socialiste Marie Noë linman
qui est sénateur socialiste également
donc tu vois tous ces gens-là et j'en
oublie Julien Baillou Alexis Corbière
donc il y a des gens de gauche il y a
des gens de droite ERC laosé chez chez
les écologistes et ce qui sont des gens
qui ont une vraie passion pour le pays
et qui sont des des des des gens dont
l'intégrité ne me questionne pas alors
c'est pas parce que je n'ai cité que
cela que et pardon par avance pour ceux
qui regarderaient ce que nous sommes en
train de faire et que j'ai oublié mais
ça ne veut pas dire que tous ceux que je
n'ai pas cité ne le sont pas mais on on
est dans un dispositif national là qui
doit préoccuper les gens qui nous
regardent parce que on est en train de
leur raconter une espèce de fable un peu
lénifiante tu vois un peu sorte
anesthésiant comme ça où on on en
appelle à notre sursaut républicain pour
barrer la route à Marine Le Pen en 2017
pour tu vois mais c'est quoi la
République c'est avant tout une justice
indépendante il n'y a il n'y a pas de
socle plus important pour la République
que l'indépendance de la justice et
aujourd'hui moi si je viens à ton micro
c'est pour témoigner de ce que la
justice n'est pas
indépendante la justice est tenue par
les hanches
ça va nous emmener où tout
ça les anars visent le
chaos tu tu tu tu sais ça évidemment
alors je me distancie de ça parce que et
dans le terme même
d'anarchie les opposants à l'anarchie
l'ont connoté négativement al c'est
l'anarchie non c'est pas ça enfin selon
la formule consacrée l'anarchie c'est la
plus haute expression de l'ordre qui qui
est fondée sur l'autogestion sur le fait
que je sais où est ma liberté où est-ce
qu'elle où est-ce qu'elle termine ce qu
respect de l'autre quelle est ma place
dans une société et cetera et j'attends
de toi si on est dans ce schéma que tu
es exactement le même type de
préoccupation donc ça va nous emmener où
je je pense que il y a un
effondrement qui arrivera et cet
effondrement il sera soit politique soit
économique et je n'arrive pas à
pronostiquer lequel des deux arrivera en
premier mais quand tu vas regarder ce
qui se
passe dans les dans les sur les places
de contestation que ce soit en France ou
étranger évidemment je regarde beaucoup
ça quand je voyage à l'étranger et je
vais beaucoup grenouiller dans des
milieux qui sont des milieux ultra
contestataire je suis très à l'aise
aussi quand je je déjeune ou je dine
avec des des dirigeants de du CAC 40
parce que tu tu tu as des GAB bien
partout j'ai pas envie d'une espèce de
machin où on serait dans un truc où on
dirait sortez vos fourches mettez des
têtes au bout des piqus et cetera c'est
pas ça mon propos mon propos c'est qu'il
faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des
cons et le bout par lequel moi je le
vois par ma formation par mon exercice
quotidien c'est c'est le droit et je je
crois que le droit est une chose qui est
trop belle pour qu'on puisse en faire
n'importe quoi comme comme comme
certains se sont arrogés de le le le
droit de le faire dans ce dossier
Société générale notamment on va revenir
sur la Société Générale la Société
Générale a-t-elle touché de l'argent
public pour se remettre à flou pendant
la crise de suprem non elle n'en a pas
touché elle l'a détourné elle est le
l'auteur du plus gros cas du siècle
puisque les gens qui te regardent là
doivent savoir que 2,2 milliards d'euros
c'est beaucoup d'argent ça veut dire
2200 millions d'euros ont été donné à la
Société Générale par le ministre
Christine Lagarde sous l'air Sarkozy en
violation euh du droit et que qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont violé oh mais euh des règles
toute à la fois fiscales comptables
parce que pour que l'affaire d'itkerervi
existe et qu'elle prospère dans le sens
de la doxa de la ligne du parti
c'est-à-dire le le la ligne de Come de
Société Générale euh relayé par l'ancien
gouverneur de la Banque de France par
François Fillon à l'époque qui disait ce
général une grande banque et cetera et
cetera je ne parle pas que de gens de
droite he c'est j'arrive sur la gauche
tout de suite après mais pour que tout
ça fonctionne il faudrait qu'il n'existe
pas de droit bancaire il faudrait qu'il
n'existe pas de droit commercial il
faudrait qu'il n'existe pas d'expertise
comptable tu comprends parce que ou
alors il faudrait qu'on nous explique
pourquoi Société Générale a violé toute
à la fois ces corpus juridiques
c'està-dire ces champs du droit
mais ils sont dans une dynamique où ils
se sont arrogés le droit de tout et
notamment de détourner cet argent
qui d'après la jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État alors je veux pas faire chier
avec mais le Conseil d'État c'est la
plus haute juridiction administrative et
elle pose que un principe au terme
duquel quand une société subit une
fraude cette fraude euh
donne droit ouvre le droit à percevoir
un/ers du montant de la
fraude sur les finances publiques mais à
deux conditions qui sont que il ne doit
pas y avoir de conivance entre le frudur
et sa hiérarchie pas de complicité il ne
doit pas y avoir de défaillance des
systèmes de contrôle de l'entreprise qui
a subi cette fraude
ok quand l'administration la garde donne
cet argent public 2 milliards dont je te
parle un l'instruction impliquant Jérôme
Kerviel débute à peine donc que
savons-nous à l'époque d'éventuelle
complicité ou du degré de connaissance
de des dirigeants de société générale la
réponse est claire c'est rien et de
Société Générale est condamné par
l'ancêtre de la CPR c'està-dire la
Commission bancaire a payé 4 millions
d'euros pour précisément défaillance de
ces systèmes de contrôle dit autrement
ça signifie que si toi et moi nous
sommes associés et qu'on se fait frauder
par des gens qui travaillent chez nous
parce qu'on s'est distribué des gros
dividendes et qu'on n pas musclé nos
services de contrôle et bien l'état
français dira fort légitimement dans ce
cas-là les garçons on ne finance pas
un/ers du montant de votre perte de
l'argent qui a été détourné ou peu
importe et là en dépit de ce que ces
deux conditions ne soient pas remplies
ne sont pas remplies et bien l'État a
tout de même décidé de donner ces 2,2
milliards d'euros sans le dire
évidemment c'est sorti 2 ans plus tard
et lorsque tu interroges cétait quelle
ça 2008 2008 ouais lorsque tu interroges
euh
Moscovici la gauche est passée il te
répond au secret fiscal lorsque tu
interroges sapin il se met à se
dendiner tu vois ça hein
dans tu trouves ça sur le sur sur le net
à l'Assemblée nationale il ment de
manière ouverte à la représentation
nationale en disant mais que
penseriez-vous de moi si je j'allais
chercher cet argent sans décision de
justice mais il en a une de décision de
justice puisque la Cour de cassation en
toute hypothèse et que les gens qui te
regardent soient d'accord avec ce que je
viens de dire ou pas on s'en fout parce
qu'en toute hypothèse la Cour de
cassation a cassé la condamnation de
Jérôme kviel sur les dommages intérêts
donc aujourd'hui Jér carviel ne doit
plus 4,9 milliards d'euros à la Société
Générale donc là il aurait dû y avoir
quelqu'un à la Société Générale qui
aurait dû rembourser cet argent là ça
toujours pas été remboursé mais non ça
n'a pas été remboursé parce que un il
n'en est pas question et de ça n'est pas
demandé par les ministre successif la
question que se la pose pour revenir sur
faut-il voter ou pas c'est comment
peut-on observer une similitude absolu
de positionnement entre un gouvernement
libéral de droite Sarkozi sous Sarkozi
et un gouvernement
socialiste donc de gauche sous Hollande
pas de différence entre les deux
administrations pas un demi degré de
différence sur le sujet sur la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte non
plus écoute tu tu je parlais d' Yan Galu
tout à l'heure euh Yann Galu ce député
et son équipe font un boulot sublime et
je regarde ça de très près à l'Assemblée
nationale pour essayer de de de
d'obtenir un statut pour les lanceurs
d'alertes mais tu comprends bien
euh que ça c'est
un sujet qui est très délicat parce que
quand les lanceurs d'alertes seront
protégés la place euh le marché
financier euh l'industrie française
européenne mondiale et cetera euh sera
mise en brèche sera battu en brèche sera
mise en danger donc on est sur un sujet
où des gens de bonne volonté ce que je
viens de citer font tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour ériger un statut pour
fabriquer un statut pour ses lanceurs
d'alerte et puis d'autres en face font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour que ça
n'adienne
pas le peuple le peuple français si on
peut résumer la population française au
peuple français le le peuple français
n'est pas conscient de ça est-ce que tu
as une idée pour essayer de leur
demander pas de se soulever mais euh de
se se saisir de de de ces
problèmes écoute moi c'est pas mon
travail d'avoir euh de de de faire des
propositions politiques mais j'ai à
titre personnel En tant que citoyen
français euh Dieu sait que je suis
attaché à à cette citoyenneté à ce pays
qui est le nôtre
euh j'ai j'ai tout un tas d'idées mais
qui seront sans doute euh jugé trop
radical allez allez mais écoute par
exemple moi je ne je ne conçois pas euh
qu'un homme ou qu'une femme politique
qui a été pris la main dans le sac et
qui soit condamné pour des détournements
de fonds publics puisse se remontrer sa
gueule en
politique jusqu'à la fin de sa vie tu tu
es pour le fait que les élus ne doivent
pas avoir de casier judiciaire ah oui
oui et puis je suis surtout pour le fait
que lorsque un homme politique tape dans
notre caisse commune je suis pour que le
peuple lui prenne tout à hauteur de ce
qu'il a tapé ou à hauteur de de de de
toutes les sommes qu' aura perçu depuis
qu'il fait de la politique parce que
toutes ces sommesl aont auront fabriqué
un chemin vers cette malhonnêteté et le
le pays au plan économique ne peut pas
supporter de tel détournements ça n'est
pas possible on n'est pas avec 2 % de
chômage avec une
croissance totalement exponentielle on
n'est pas rendu là on a des problèmes de
d'incarcération on a des problèmes de
réinsertion on a des problèmes à l'éduc
national parce que tu as tu as tu as des
tu as des gamins qui arrivent en 6e sans
savoir lire et écrire on a des problèmes
dans les quartiers on a des problèmes de
santé publies tu vois donc on n
pasè écoute
euh poudrière je je ne sais pas mais moi
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui comment un un
un tel schéma peut continuer à à
perdurer aussi souverainement que que ce
qu'il perdurait quand il y avait trois
chaînes de télévision et les journaux du
matin et quelquesuns du soir et je pense
que les réseaux sociaux euh sont à
regarder comme l'était les messagers du
Pont Neuf pendant la Révolution
française parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui ce
qui se passe c'est et ça c'est important
pour pour les gens qui soutiennent des
positions telles que tel que tel que les
nôtres et tu sais ma proximité
avec avec ces ces milieux contestataires
quand nous défendons des des des
hackeurs des Anonymous des
cryptoanarchistes des bon voilà on ne
fait pas que ça on a aussi un un un
travail d'avocat d'affaires parce qu'il
faut que tout ça se rééquilibre euh et
que c'est ça que j'étais avant de de que
ces gens-là face de moi un avocat
militant tu vois un quasi avocat
gevariste qui a un statut qui m'ennuie
parurs tu tu comment te formuler ça tu
qu'est-ce qui t'anime toi en tant
qu'homme qu'est-ce qui te fait vivre
qu'est-ce qui te fait souffler qu'est-ce
qui te fait te te reposer quand tua
pléder en face de de des pierres
menteurs tu fais quoi pour survivre
cette cette ultra stimulation de ton
cerveau tu fais quoi pour ta'airer
d'abord c'est pas si dur que ça d'y
survivre parce que dans ce champ
professionnel ce qui m'anime c'est je te
l'ai dit le serment que j'ai prêté et je
pense que re tu sacrifierais ta vie pour
ton serment euh
elle est compliqué ta question mais
euh si imagine-toi
demain je suis ton adversaire et je te
pose un milliard d'euros sur la table et
je te dis bon maintenant ça suffit non
non mais oui non ça ça revient à ça
revient à être à vendre on n'est pas à
vendre nous c'est pas quoi qu'il arrive
on dit tout le monde a un prix non non
il y a pas de prix comme ça Société
Générale connaît très bien les règles du
jeu parce que ils ont fait la connerie
de dire publiquement que acheté c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche il ils ont
dit publiquement en violant le le les
règles déontologiques qui régissent la
profession d'avocat qu'ils allaient
négocier avec les avocats carevien donc
ça ça y est c'est public les
négociations entre avocats sont en
théorie confidentielles nous nos
conditions pour s'arrêter elles sont
très simple un il s'excuse publiquement
et deux il dédommage carviel les témoins
et le lanceurs d'alerte dont ils ont
pourri la vie et ça s'arrêtera pour eux
et on expliquera à partir de ce
moment-là que c'est une il s'agit d'une
banque vertueuse mais avant ça elle ne
peut pas être vue comme étant une banque
vertueuse donc tu vois dans ce contexte
c'est pas très compliqué pour moi de me
détendre parce que je suis pas très
tendu parce que ce qui nous anime au
sein du cabinet 28 octobre qui est le
qui est le cabinet à laquel auquel
pardon j'ai la la chance d'appartenir
pourquoi 28 octobre
euh pour tout un tas de raisons dans
lesquelles on va pas rentrer là mais en
tout cas principalement pour que tu
poses la question et tu vois ça ça
fonctionne mais blague à
part la justice est un sous-jacent qui
est très très preignant chez nous très
présent et la beauté du combat donc tout
ça ça nous fatigue pas parce qu'on a on
on s'est cablé à l'envers donc s'il
devait y avoir des menaces s'il devait y
avoir des pressions s'il devait y avoir
des choses pour essayer de nous
impressionner un peu comme nous ne
sommes pas des avocats particulièrement
douillés ça nous donnerait plus
desessens que de en fait dans ces
dossiers il faut enlever la trouille de
l'équation sinon il faut faire ch tu
t'es fait tu t'es fait cogner quand même
non je me suis fait agresser mais on a
pas d'éléments qui permettent de dire si
c'est en lien ou pas donc ça n'est pas
en lien parce que par il faut pas
fantasmer les choses je me suis fait
agresser il y a longtemps mais tout ça
est et désormais derrière et et dans ma
vie à moi dans ma vie d'homme je je je
vois mes amis j'ai la chance d'être dans
un super projet avec un un homme auquel
je veux rendre hommage qui s'appelle
David Chatelus qui est un menuisier de
génie on dessine des meubles ensemble je
suis allé le voir avec un dessin que
j'avais envie de de décliner et moi je
n'avais pas la compéten pour faire ça
mon mon grand-père paternel était
etbéniste d'art donc tu vois c'est
quelque chose avec quoi je je je renoue
et donc on on s'associe tous les deux
sur ce projet pour fabriquer des meubles
parce que si tu veux quand tu quand tu
brasses des
euh des chiffres comme ça dans les
dossiers et cetera il faut faire
attention de pas se décaler du réel trop
tu penses que les hommes politiques sont
complètement à l'ouest oui oui oui mais
mais mais aussi un certain nombre
d'avocats tu vois le le dossier Société
Générale que tu évoquais au
début ça cause en milliards au bout d'un
moment tu sais plus de quoi tu
parles tu vois moi quand je suis rentré
dans ce dossier j'ai dû me dire alors
attends merde comment s'écrit un
milliard ouais tu vois comment comment
s'écrit un milliard c'est quoi c'est
combien de millions c'est quoi tuis
parce que pas des choses que tu que tu
mouvementes quotidiennement et et donc
je trouve que c'est bien de d'aller se
planquer au au faubourg là de temps en
temps dans son atelier pour pour
dessiner des trucs discuter avec lui
couper des machins visser des bidules
coller des trucs tu vois donc ça c'est
c'est une activité qui et je pense que
en vieillissant j'aurais besoin de
vendre quelque chose c'està-dire de
d'avoir un rapport à l'argent qui est
moi j'ai fabriqué ça et toi ça te plaît
alors donne-moi de l'argent pour que je
te donne mon machin parce que là on est
dans une une espèce de de nous en tout
cas avec le boulot qu'on fait dans une
espèce d'économie qui est totalement
euh immatérielle non est pas virtuelle
parce qu'on vend du temps mais euh voilà
donc on enfin notre cabinet est
structuré il y a y a il y a plus d'une
vingtaine d'avocats dedans tout le monde
traite des dossiers enfin tout est bien
mais euh je je pense que quand tout sera
fini et quand j'aurai envie de passer à
autre chose je je je resterai avocat
pour traiter quelques dossiers par an et
que j'aurais envie de fabriquer des des
des bidules tu vois Jérôme il est dans
quel état maintenant là il a touché
450000 du moin et on lui a fait un
jugement au prudom pour 450000 € avec
80000 € payable de suite que Société
Générale fera tout pour ne pas payer en
expliquant médiatiquement que ils ont
plus d'argent en expliquant
médiatiquement que Jérôme carviel leur
doit 4,9 milliards d'euros ce qui est
faux hein puisque entre quand je te l'ai
dit il a il y a 5 minutes et maintenant
ça cette somme demeure cassée par la
Cour de cassation mais ils sont dans un
degré de contrariété qui se mesure quand
tu regardes les interviews de de leurs
avocats sur les plateaux ou moi j'ai
l'impression de voir une espèce de de
stratégie de canard sans tête tu vois où
tu vois mon mon confrère jeanveille
partir sur les plateaux pour expliquer
aux journalistes de BFM notamment que
toutes nos procédures vont être classées
sans suite qu'il y aura des nonlieux que
Société Générale va triompher il te dit
ça c'est dans 6 mois ça c'est dans 2 ans
enfin cet homme semble peiner à
comprendre que ce qui lui est reproché
c'est très précisément ça que la justice
n'est pas une institution que tu peux
tenir par la main ni quand tu es un
avocat ni quand tu es un politique sinon
ça n'est plus la justice est autre chose
voilà dans quel état Jérôme il est très
sincèrement il est fatigué de tout ça
euh parce que c'est un ans c'est 8 ans
de combat il a fait de la TLE il a été
voir le pape il a été marché
voir le Saint-Père et R est rentrer de
Rome à pied euh c'était c'était une
c'était un épisode qui
était fantastique pour lui il dit que
c'était cette marche était au rang des
plus des plus des meilleurs moments de
sa vie et je le crois parce qu'il était
tout seul il était tu vois il était dans
une chose qui je veux pas dire que quand
tu es tout seul c'est le meilleur moment
de ta vie ce que je veux dire c'est que
il a eu il a eu un temps introspectif
qui lui a permis de se retrouver de se
parce que tu vois enfin c'est des c'est
des ce sont des des parcours des destins
euh qui ressemble un peu à des
lessiveuses quand même tu vois à partir
du moment où ça claque en janvier 2008
jusqu'à
maintenant il y a eu un certain nombre
de
d'instances il y a eu un certain nombre
de contrariété il y a eu un certain
nombre de d'espoir parfois déçus tu vois
euh
il y a eu des convocations il y a eu des
et et donc là il s'est voit sur son
visage quand on le voit apparaître il
est marqué estce qu'il qui le serait pas
Sky est-ce qu'ils ont cherché à le à le
tuer au sens le tuer comme on pourrait
l'admettre non évidemment pas
euh est-ce que dans leur c'est une
procédure Bayon c'est c'est est-ce que
dans leur bande il y en a un qui est
suffisant ment intelligent pour se dire
que n'importe qui soumis à ce à quoi ils
l'ont soumis pourrait décider de se
suicider euh je souhaite pas insulter
leur intelligence donc je te répondrai
qu'il y en a plusieurs qui ont pu faire
ce calcul là oui c'est de se dire
comment tu tiens quand tu es Jérôme
gerviel et là il est passé d'un schéma
de survie à un schéma de vie parce
qu'aujourd'hui la troule SER insée il
fait quoi là en ce moment mais il est
pas désinséré il est pas question pour
lui de se réinséré il n'est pas un
délinquant il est il est un homme
honorable il est un homme
honnête c'est pas c'est pas nous les
délincants c'est pas nous les
malhonnêtes c'est pas nous sa vie fait
quoi là en ce moment il travaille où il
travaille beaucoup sur le dossier il a
monté une boîte avec un de ses amis un
de s un de ses proches donc il lance une
activité et puis il est il est très tenu
dans dans ce dans ce combat dans
lequel il n'a pas été invité qui est un
combat qu'on lui a imposé et il avait le
choix entre céder et combattre et
et ce genre de bestiol ça cède pas il
avait un bon avocat bon le non non non
lui lui lui tel qu'il est foutu il cède
pas ça a rien à voir avec moi c'est du
breton ouais c'est du breton ouais
qu'est-ce qui reste encore comme procès
avec la Société Générale
euh 15 16 17 juin mercredi jeudi
vendredi nous sommes à la cour d'appel
de Versailles euh pour euh évaluer euh
d'après ce que nous dit le la Cour de
cassation les fautes de Société Générale
pour savoir si kviel doit quelque chose
à la générale ou pas euh donc
nous nous y euh nous y allons nous y
allons sereinement mais ça c'est la
queue du dossier initial de 2008 il
reste les trois plaintes que nous avons
déposé euh contre cette très honorable
banque des plaines pour faux usage de
faux escroocerie au jugement et
subornation de témoins euh qui sont en
cours d'instruction au pôle financier de
Paris il reste l'appel puisqu'il paraît
que Société Générale a a a envie de de
rejo un round sur le le prudom le prudom
donc c'est parfait nous le rejouerons
euh et puis il reste les procédures qui
émaneront des nouveaux éléments dont
nous disposons et que nous n'avons pas
encore
exploité ni pleinement exploité ni
exploité du tout d'ailleurs et qui là
montre dans une granule ité beaucoup
plus fine qui qui a tenu la main de qui
à quelle fin à quelle date et donc on
arrive dans une partie qui va être euh
nécessairement
violente ça sera
brutal parce que ce type
d'institution se défend
euh et c'est son droit de tenter de le
faire mais moi je ne vois plus aucune
fin de l'histoire où Jérôme carviel perd
là où nous en sommes rendus avec avec ce
dont nous disposons parce que nous
dénonçons un procès qui a été
manipulé un procès qui a été trué c'est
c'est un procès truc ça fait des années
qu'on vous dit ça et ça fait des années
que personne ne me convoque moi avocat
auxiliaire de justice en disant bon
écoutez vous êtes en train de dire des
choses qui sont graves il faut s'arrêter
parce que et cetera on ne me dit pas non
plus montrez-nous vos éléments on est
dans une espèce de machin où il ne faut
pas en parler on tourne la tête oui
voilà c'est ça et nous notre boulot
c'est de prendre cette tête et de la
remettre dans l'axe parce qu'il y a un
sujet qui est là que nous avons posé là
ça fait des mois que nous travaillons
sur la manière
dont cette mascarade a été fabriqué
quand tu entends des phrases
comme c'est délicat de rentrer dans le
détail là mais quand tu entends des
phrases comme euh euh
vous n'arriverez à
rien parce que tout le monde a été
prévenu ça t' ça t'évoque quoi ça
t'évoque un combat qui qui s'annonce de
manière loyale non tu vois
donc aujourd'hui on a des des
professionnels de la justice qui nous
ont rallié je te renvoie une une tribune
très très émouvante pour l'avocat que je
suis qui s'appelle pour l'honneur de la
justice il faut rejuger carviel qui a
écrit ça le premier avocat général près
la Cour de cassation qui est un homme
qui s'appelle Yv Charpenel donc je te
demande de mesurer le courage pour
prendre une telle position il emmène
avec lui Jean de Maillard qui est
vice-président tribunal de grande
instance il emmène Hélène Franco et
George Fennec magistrate ancien euh juge
d'instruction enfin tu vois donc on a
des magistrats ici qui disent si la
justice est trompée c'est qu'elle a été
trompée et c'est bien ce dont on parle
et que tu le regardes euh avec mes
lunettes d'avocat
ou avec tes lunettes de citoyens ou les
miennes d'ailleurs puisque part les
mêmes lunettes souvent mais tu ne peux
pas admettre de mon point de vue que que
la justice soit tenue ainsi qu'elle est
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
admissible et tu sais à quoi on sait
qu'on a raison c'est ce que je te disais
parce que personne ne nous a rien
demandé parce que les accusations que
nous portons sont des des accusations
qui sont sourdes qui sont
graves tu te figures bien que si nous
avions tort si nous étions là pour
vendre des t-shirts avec marqué justice
ou je sais pas quoi si c'était ça notre
business on nous aurait tapé sur le
dessus du Crâ en nous disant qu'est-ce
que vous racontez vous êtes condamné
vous êtes poursuivi vous êtes suspendu
en tant qu'avocat vous êtes admonesté
vous il ne se passe rien alors tu as des
journalistes d'investigation comme Denis
Robert comme Martine orange
Médiapart des journalistes comme Vincent
antigame comme Nicolas Cory qui est au
jour qui tu as des gens qui ont fait ce
travail- làà d'aller regarder très
précisément ce qui se passe donc ça sort
ça fait un boom médiatique et puis ça
redescend ça se délite parce qu'il y a
le boom médiatique d'après donc quand tu
me demandais tout à l'heure euh
qu'est-ce que nous pourrions faire au
plan collectif par exemple fabriquer un
endroit qui peut être virtuel hein qui
peut être numérique euh qui est un
endroit où nous suivrions collectivement
en tant que citoyen un peu comme des
vigis citoyennes euh qu'ad devent-il de
tel ministre qui est pris dans telle
affaire parce que mon approche ce n'est
pas de se dire euh je me réjouis que tel
ou tel ministre soit la une des journaux
que son nom soit salopé euh qu'il soit
infamé partout et qu'on disent oh le
voleur le menteur le manipulateur le
celui qui a détourné et cetera et puis
qu'après il se passe rien pas ça le
sujet moi je préférerais plus de réserve
dans la phase du boom tu vois euh
lorsque lorsque je travaillais par
exemple contre dominiic stroskanan euh
en
2011 dans la fameuse affaireire Banon
ouais euh j'étais moin gêné par euh tout
ce qui était écrit et dit sur stroscan
qui allait
au-delà de sa responsabilité ou de son
innocence pénale moi je ne suis pas là
pour fabriquer des alalis des lychages
c'est pas ça mais en revanche un peu de
suivi sur le cas de tel ou tel qui aura
contribué à manipuler la justice je je
sors de l'exemple que je j'évoqué à
l'instant mais un peu de suivi pour
répondre à ta question qu'est-ce qu'on
fait nous au plan collectif citoyen
français bah ça ne serait pas
complètement inepte parce que tu vois on
n'est pas dans un schéma aujourd'hui de
politique contractuelle on n'est pas
dans un schéma où si tu te présentes à
mon vote et que tu l'obtiens et que tu
es élu je peux te demander des comptes
donc l'institution se protège les
institutions politiques se protègent de
ça en disant si la sanction d'après
c'est le vote d'après mais ça veut dire
que tu as un blanc sain pendant un
quinqu pendant 5 ans ça ça marche pas
moi j'aimerais bien pour aller voter
pour la première fois de ma vie ce qu'il
faudrait c'est qu'on me dit dise si toi
tu te présentes et que tu es élu tu es
engagé parce que tu as présenté parce
que tu as promis et si tu n'y arrives
pas bah ça nous va bien au plan
collectif que tu dégages tu as qu'à
aller faire des des des implants
capillaires comme tu faisais avant tu
vois ou tuas tu as qu'à retourner faire
l'avocat ou tu as qu'à aller t'occuper
d'autre chose que de la chose publique
le bien publ l'intérêt général qu'est-ce
que tu penses de l'avocat qui a été
interné d'office écoute je je je ne
connais pas le dossier donc c'est c'est
compliqué pour un avocat de alors
évidemment si ce que j'ai lu est
exactement ce qui s'est passé ça
ressemble à une petite carambouille
médiocre des gens qu'il a dû emmerder
euh si ce que j'ai lu est est
fondé je je trouve que on vient nous
emmerder de plus en plus près euh les
avocats tu vois alors non pas qu'on ait
besoin parce que nos activités seraient
tellement secrètes ou tellement
délicates de d'avoir des des des passes
droit c'est pas ça que je dis mais les
droits de la défense ça suppose que les
avocats ne soient pas muselés ça suppose
que les avocats ne soient pas emmerdés
dans leur quotidien et j'ai été assez
préoccupé tu vois par exemple s'agissant
des
écoutes de de de Sarkozi et de son
avocat je trouve particulièrement
inadmissible que la conversation que
peut avoir un avocat avec son client
puisse être entendu qu'est-ce que tu
penses de l'état d'urgence et que la
mais quel état d'urgence ouais quel état
d'urgence je pr il a pasétat
d'urgence pardon te coup il y a pas
d'état d'urgence enfin dis-moi mais
pourquoi il y a pas d'état d'urgence
mais parce que quand tu
as quand tu as un ancien président de la
République un ancien Premier ministre un
président de la République en fonction
un premier ministre en fonction qui
t'explique que tu es en que ton pays est
en guerre est-ce que tu as le droit en
tant que citoyen de de constater que tu
es protégé oui tu as ce droit c'est un
droit
fondamental c'est quoi la protection
aujourd'hui c'est quand tu rentres dans
un centre commercial une sécurité privée
qui te dit ouvrez votre sac tu fais
comme ça et puis tu planques ce que tu
veux dessous je veux dire si on est en
guerre alors il faut que nous soyons
armés alors pas toi moi n'importe qui
mais les réservistes les flic en civils
les gens endarmement civil tu
vois le
Bataclan qui a été un carnage absolu ça
ça existe parce que personne n'est armé
personne parmi les gens qui te regardent
là ne vont croire que cette menace là
est
arrivée du jour au lendemain il la Libye
il y a eu la Syrie mais non mais mais
mais mais intéresse-toi à notre pays il
y a eu ma mais Mera c'était pas grave
c'était des enfants juifs et puis
c'était des militaires alors tu vois
c'est ni toi ni moi c'est des Juifs
enfants et des militaires ensuite il y a
eu Charlie c'est ni toi ni moi c'est
journalistes c'est des journaliste là
merde des terrasses de café des
terrasses de con de concert donc là
enfin des salles de concert donc là ça
peut être toi et moi mais cette
utilisation politique qui a été faite de
tous ces attentats c'est là où je
voulais que tu ou c'est une utilisation
politique mais bien évidemment mais bien
évidemment ça n'est rien d'autre qu'une
utilisation politique c'està-dire que
Fermine de découvrir que cette menace
existe et je rentre pas dans le fond de
cette menace parce que je suis pas
compétent pour le pour le faire je j'ai
une vision qui une vision strictement
française je je sais pas comment je
réagirais si j'étais libien
syrien d'une autre confession que la
mienne j'en sais rien donc je veux pas
rentrer là-dedans tu as une confession
on en reparlera après continue non j'ai
une religion de naissance mais je n'ai
pas de confession mais je répondrai à
tes questions évidemment mais donc je
sais pas comment je réagirais si si je
voyais les choses de manière un peu
excentrée mais pour autant nous faire
croire que tout ça a bien là maintenant
comme ça mais c'est prendre pour des
cons le secret des correspondances
l'état d'urgence tu es avocat tu es mon
avocat mon téléphone est écouté on a
plus de secret des correspondances c'est
ça je peux plus parler tranquillement à
mon avocat non tu peux pas non tu peux
pas parler tranquillement à ton avocat
et et tu ne peux pas être
défendu avec les droits de la défense
qui te sont qui te sont alloués par le
petit livre rouge qui s'appelle le code
pénal tout ça n'est pas appliqué ENF ça
dépend de la connerie que tu feras si
c'est une connerie qui gêne personne bah
oui tout se passera bien si c'est une
connerie qui gne
l'Élysée ça va être plus compliqué pour
toi donc en fait si tu n'es pas un cas
d'anomalie tu
Peras Jérôme kviel c'est une
anomalie faut comprendre
ça que n'importe qui ne supporte pas ce
qu'il a traversé
comme il a été capable de le supporter
c'est un fantôme à l'heure actuelle non
pas du tout il n'a jamais été aussi
vivant il est il est
euh dans un état que que que je
trouve globalement préoccupant il y a
une copine c'est pas des questions
qu'elle je répond c'est pas préoccupant
pourquoi son état
euh parce qu'il est soumis à rue
d'épreuve parce que moi je sais pas ce
que c'est ça fait de se lever tous les
matins pendant 8 ans et que ton nom de
famille ton nom patronymique le nom de
ton père le nom de ta lignée le nom des
tiens soit traîné dans la boue par par
quatre connards qui sont là pour pour
servir d'autres intérêts
que combien ça prend un avocat qui sert
ce type d'intérêt tu
sais c'est en million d'euros en million
d'euros bien sûr pour toute la procédure
ou en plusieurs millions d'euros oui
bien sûr ou bien sûr combien tu prends
toi bah zé
je prendrai un pourcentage de de ce que
nous gagnerons à la
fin tu es un vrai toi tu lâches à rien
ben je t'ai dit je prêté ce serment
et enfin moi je suis devenu avocat pour
il y a là tout ce qui fait que j'ai eu
envie d'être un tu sais pourquoi moi je
t'ai pris comme avocat parce qu'un jour
je t'ai appelé et tu m'as dit si tarrive
quoi que ce soit je brûlerai tout pour
te défendre h
oui parce que parce que je sais les
intérêts que tu que tu défend
et que ses intérêts font
écho aux intérêts que que je défends si
tu avais un conseil pour les jeune
génération soulevez-vous soulevez-vous
ouais
comment avec du talent avec du respect
avec de l'inventivité mais soulevez-vous
et restez et arrêtez de rester assis sur
vos cul parce que ça va pas bien se
passer tu sais j'ai croisé un
j'étais à j'étais à l'Élysée il y a il y
a y a quelques temps de cela j'ai croisé
un très
haut
conseiller quelqu'un qui dure dans le
temps comme ça et on
discutait à une autre occasion et il me
disait je viens de donner pour conseil à
des étudiants de faire la
révolution est-ce que tu te rends compte
de la farce et tu as des gens à l'Élysée
je te parle d'autres gens parce que je
je grenouille beaucoup dans ces milieux
politiques parce que notre stratégie
dans le dossier Société Générale ça a
été d'alerter l'opinion j'assume ça ça a
été d'alerter le politique
euh je fais pas croire que je vais
m'encarter là là ou là hein tu as bien
vu qu'on est très en retrait par rapport
au risque de manipulation de reprise il
y a toujours vous allez vous faire c'est
quoi le terme vous allez vous
faire pas reprendre comment dit-on
récupérer récupérer le risque de merci
le risque de récupération tu vois bien
qu'on est récupéré par personne on est
capable d'aller avec Jérôme carviel à la
Fête de l'Humanité invité par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on a des critiques de certains
cassiques du Parti socialiste et ceetera
so on leur répondait mais n'ayez pas
peur ce sont des gens de
gauche tu vois on a dit à Hollande à
Vals n'ayez pas peur des gens de gauche
Hollande il est toujours à gauche mais
non mais non Hollande il est pas à
gauche il P de Holland mais j'en pense
rien j'en pense que je suis navré je
pense que quand on est le premier
magistrat de France et quand on a en
main ce qu'il a en main sur le
dysfonctionnement de cet appareil qui
est un appareil noble c'estd que la
justice c'est le truc qui fait que je
peux pas me comporter avec toi comme
j'ai envie de me comporter si je suis
dans un jour où je dévisse c'est le truc
qui fait que tu peux pas me tuer que tu
peux pas me violer que tu peux pas me me
voler que tu peux pas te comporter donc
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
important dans un dispositif
démocratique et quand on sait ce qu'il a
en main sur ce dossier un certain nombre
d'autres et quand on voit l'inertie qui
est attaché à l'une quelconque de ces
actions mais c'est à
vomir c'est à vomir c'est pour ça qu'à
la question on est quoi à la question
euh est-ce que tu votes qu'est-ce que tu
veux que je te réponde pour qui je vais
voter moi je je je n'ai pas envie de
voter pour des espèces de clans
euh tu vois qui bouffent ensemble qui
s'envoient des SMS et puis qui font
semblant de s'écharper pour faire de la
politique Entertainment
euh euh pour les cons du peuple c'est
une caste mais ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'une caste qu'est-ce que tu
crois ça sort de l'enat euh un jour on
se dira peut-être collectivement qu'il
faut fermer l'enat
ou que si on ferme pas l'enat on a
peut-être le droit d'être conseiller
politique mais pas de se soumettre au
mandat mais tu tu te rends compte des
réseaux que ça fabrique
Lena enfin c'est c'est des choses où euh
on ne se tue pas entre nous quand on a
une arc donc évidemment que c'est une
caste ça n'est rien d'autre qu'une caste
enfin moi je vois ça comme des gang en
fait hein pour tout te dire je je vais
un peu au-delà et je suis pas en train
de me laisser emporter
par le fait que nous nous connaissions
le fait qu'on soit dans un endroit
agréable ou je je suis tout à fait
conscient que nous sommes filmés que
nous sommes en interview donc je suis
pas dans une espèce d'emballement et ça
quand tu es dans un média classique
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui m'a conduit à
accepter ton ton invitation je te
remercie pour ça mais quand tu es dans
un média classique et que tu tu tu
tentes d'évoquer ces sujets on te dit
oui oui d'accord ben non c'est pas
d'accord non justement on en parle parce
que c'est pas d'accord c'est tout som
d'accord tu
comprends qu'est-ce
que et après qu'est-ce qu'on fait après
si on arrive un petit peu à récupérer
notre système judiciaire notre
justice si Athena rend la justice avec
mais tu sais il y a un programme
politique qui est tout à fait
révolutionnaire et qui est à notre
portée je te dis que c'est
révolutionnaire parce que ça n'a jamais
été fait c'est application de la loi aux
banques application de la loi à la
finance application de la loi à tous
parce qu'à l'Assemblée nationale quand
tu vois qu'il y a des débats on te dit
il faut légiférer là-dessus alors c'est
l'état d'urgence alors en congrès on
réunit tout ça et cetera et cetera non
non mais on a besoin de rien on a des
lois qui fonctionnent très très bien on
a un système judiciaire qui est crois-le
bien très très très
performant mais encore faut-il appliquer
la loi à tous parce que si c'est à
quelques uns et pas à d'autres bah c'est
plus la loi c'est autre
chose est-ce que tu as des questions à
nous poser à vous ouais plein C oram bah
oui plein or cam évidemment mais mais tu
vois je je pense pour répondre à ta
question qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'il y a après et cetera je
je pense que chacun d'entre nous se doit
avec les moyens qu'il a les petits
talents qu'il a les idées qu'il a
d'essayer de faire avancer là je suis en
train de bosser avec avec une humoriste
qui s'appelle ella Kellan on a on a
travailler ensemble sur un spectacle
politique qui s'appelle les
condescendants qui jouent au théâtre en
ce moment et on on on explique un peu
aux gens de manière j'ai coécrit ça avec
Ella et elle
euh on a décidé que je mettais ce
spectacle en scène euh bon la mise en
scène est une vaste arnaque parce Queen
fait c'est c'est une c'est une humoriste
qui se qui se pense de droite et qui est
tout à fait incontrôlable donc elle
bouge comme elle veut sur scène et tout
ça est très marrant mais bon je je suis
censé être le metteur en scène du machin
ce que je n'avais jamais fait mais c'est
c'est chouette de voir tu vois le
fonctionnement de ces gens et et et
l'idée moi quand je vais dans un truc
comme ça c'est pour me dire ben ce que
j'arrive pas à faire quand je suis euh
dans un prêtoir que ce que je n'arrive
pas à faire quand je suis en interview
au grand journal ou dans un JT ou sur
BFM sur iTélé ou je sais pas quoi ce que
je n'arrive pas à faire par une tribune
en Une de l'UMA ou ou une interview dans
Médiapart ou je sais pas quoi ben
peut-être que je vais arriver à le faire
un peu
différemment en s'essayant comme ça à
l'humour donc on passe ces messages
comme ça ça ça c'est une vision très
douce parce que moi je fais ça pour me
détendre et que que ma part de combat je
pense que je la porte tu vois donc j'ai
pas besoin d'aller m'engager dans autre
chose pour me donner de l'adrénaline on
est bien au niveau adrénaline là déjà
mais mais mais je pense que ce
soulèvement euh est inévitable si on
veut
éviter un effondrement mais aujourd'hui
tu as de très grandes banques françaises
et européennes qui sont virtuellement en
faillite des pays qui sont c'est là où
je voulais te poser la question est-ce
que tu penses pas que l'État était si
prévenant et avenant avec la SG c'est
parce que c'est une grande banque et que
cette grande banque si par exemple elle
coule ou qui est 25 lanceur d'Al
d'alerte qui se réveille suite à au fait
que tu peut-être gagneras l'intégralité
de ton procès est-ce que tu penses pas
que si une de nos grandes banques
vacille ça mettrait la France dans une
situation à l'internationale d'une
façon si délétaire que on coulerait
d'autant plus vite est-ce que est-ce
queil y a c'est pas un procès
géopolitique cette banque mais oui salé
mais je te retourne une question si elle
a
malagi euh est-ce que c'est parce
qu'elle est est grande respectable
systémique et qui aurait des
conséquences que que qu'on doit lui
donner un blanc sein et et la laisser
filer parce que je vais te dire une
chose to big to fail ouais mais ça moi
j'y crois pas moi j'y crois pas je crois
pas à ça moi je crois pas à ça j'entends
pas ce propos la Dodge P c'est un effet
de levier de 90 c'est plus de 2000
milliards ouais mais attends c'est pas
on sait pas où on en est de la Dodge ban
là ouais c'est une cerude oui mais voilà
mais on en a vu des on en a vu des plus
grosses se mettre genou à terre euh que
la deutche écoute moi je suis impliqué
dans un certain nombre de de Dossi en
tant qu'avocat où
euh les gentils dirigeants de banque euh
pointent du doigt un certain nombre de
trader en disant voilà les salopards euh
nous on s'occupe de vous les brûler
médiatiquement maintenant brûlez-les
judiciairement et puis on Pera l'amende
que vous direz parce que ça c'est du fre
qui s'en foute mais vous venez pas nous
emmerder sur nos licences de de
bancaires mais si si je suis le
raisonnement pour Société Générale par
exemple qui est un groupe que je connais
particulièrement bien parce que ces gens
ont fait de nous des passionnés je pense
que c'est une erreur de leur part mais
c'est ça qui s'est
passé Société générale si jamais je
décide de la croire un instant
c'està-dire elle n'a pas vu qu'un trader
Junior a engagé sur les marché 50
milliards d'euros de pause de position
elle l' pas vu
elle a pas vu que pendant toute l'année
2007 les activités
de son petit délincant de
trader avait généré 26 milliards d'euros
d'entrée et de sortie de cash sur ses
comptes de dépôt de
garantie complémenté par des appels de
marge tu sais pour suivre le les
variations de marché elle a pas vu ça ça
veut dire que chez Société Générale tu
peux sortir et rentrer 26 milliards
d'euros dans une année sans que personne
ne voit rien qui est-ce qui fait le
système de sécurité si c'est le cas mais
le systèmecit
Société Générale est imbattable
d'ailleurs ils étaient en train de le
vendre dans un rocho européen pour le
licencier sous marque blanche pour
d'autres banque tu vois donc il pas pas
de problème de sécurité ça c'est la
parlotte tu vois pour dire on n pas vu
on préfère être con complice d' un truc
tu
vois tu vois mais si tout ça est vrai
s'ils ont raison alors ok on
condamneien mais dans ce caslx il faut
les fermer
il y a pas de poids et de mesure si dans
une institution bancaire dont tu me dis
qu'elle a un impact systémique et
d'ailleurs c'est le grande manière de se
défendre c'estàd on est tellement la
Société Générale que s'il nous arrivit
quelque chose alors ils ont plusieurs
rideaux argumentaires le premier rideau
c'est on a 160000 salariés qui vont
partir au tapis et cetera mais il s'agit
pas de fermer Société générale il s'agit
de faire en sorte que le gouvernement
français fasse ce qu'il faut pour
qu'elle arrête de faire n'importe
quoi dans sa gestion du
risque ça ça devrait être la
préoccupation du politique moi ma
préoccupation d'avocat c'est qu'elle
arrête de brûler des gens parce que de
temps en temps faut sortir du placard un
gars qu'on va aller carboniser en public
pour ne pas avoir à s'expliquer sur nos
propres turpitudes tu vois c'est comme
ça qu'ils font la chose mais si tout ça
est vrai dans ce cas-là il y a pas une
autorité des marchés financiers
il y a pas la CPR la MF il y a rien tout
ça oui ben non il y a
pas donc là dans Panama papers par
exemple tu as vu dans la presse
perquisition Société Générale ou au
Luxembourg non non à Paris ils vont
trouver quoi qu'est-ce le truc est
absurde tu vois bien donc on fait des
espèces de petits SIG et de petits SAG
comme ça qui sont des het médiatiques
pour te dire bon voilà on a fait le job
et nous notre boulot que ce soit dans
Panama papers ù
je travaillais en tant qu'avocat pour un
des sénateurs devant lesquels Frédéric
oudea a dit qu'il n'avait pas d'activité
directeur général de Société Générale
n'avait pas d'activité dans les pays de
la liste grise en ce qui concerne les
sociétés générales pas au Panama et puis
on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des
activités et des activités multiples et
florissantes dans cette zone
géographique Panama que ce soit dans
Panama papers ou dans Kerviel
tu tu es dans un dispositif o
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus fonctionner
comme
avant peut pas laisser filer ça donc moi
mon boulot parce que ce sont mes
adversaires parce que je trouve qu'ils
sont en train de d'abord salir l'image
de la finan par ailleurs prendre leurs
actionnaires pour des crétins parce que
ce qu'il
raconte c'est pas vrai et puis ensuite
tronquer le cours de la justice mon
boulot c'est de te dire ça et de te le
dire jusqu'à ce que ça
passe et et pour cela il faut politiser
le dossier donc c'est cette stratégie
que nous mettons en œuvre pendant que
eux nous décrivent comme des gens
turbulents pas bien structurés tu sais
moi il faut par exemple que je sois un
communiquant quand il parle de moi ce
sont des éléments de langage tu sais ce
que c'est les éléments de langage quand
il parle de moi il ne parle jamais de
moi comme d'un avocat il parle de moi
comme dans comme d'
communiant par que je open parce que si
jamais je suis communicant ben je
communique pas si je suis avocat c'est
un peu plus chiant alors enfin moi je
sais qui je suis j'ai pas tu vois j'ai
pas de problème avec ça on va terminer
par une dernière question
euh comment tu vois la France dans 5
ans
euh
je je je vois plusieurs euh
scénaris qui se qui se chevauche et et
j'espère que je me trompe sur sur chacun
d'entre eux je je pense très sincèrement
que s'il n'y a pas un un éveil un réveil
collectif maintenant je pense que si on
ne va pas demander de compte à nos à nos
dirigeants et moi je suis d'accord pour
que ça ne se passe pas viol violemment
je n'exige
pas que cette révolution soit
nécessairement violente c'est pas c'est
pas ça que j'exige mais je pense que si
on ne les met pas
euh en face des
responsabilités qui sont les leurs et
s'ils ne se mettent pas à faire le job
pour lequel ils ont tous ces avantages
totalement exorbitants de la vie
courante des Français parce que je sais
pas si tu tu sais bien comment ces gens
là vivent quand ils gouvernent mais mais
c'est
fou c'est fou et quel que soit le bout
par lequel tu le prends quand tu vois
8000 € de coiffeur pour un pour un gars
comme François Hollande par mois payer
sur des fonds publics tu te marres quand
tu vois un ministre qui rentre chez lui
avec trois bagnoles de flic truc machin
tu te tu te marre
euh ce qui est rigolo aussi c'est
quand tu vois toi un ministre dans le
cadre d'un rendez-vous d'agrément amical
et qui débarque avec toute cette espèce
de de
de d'entourage qui coûte de l'argent en
français tu vois tu évoqué l'état
d'urgence tout à l'heure je je je me
suis pas documenté je sais pas combien
ça coûte mais ça coûte forcément
deargent public pour un truc où on voit
très bien qu'on est trouable de partout
il y a pas de sécurité dans les
trains tu vois quand tu prends un train
pour aller à Londres bah on sait faire
des portiques comme dans les aéroports
alors au premier attentat j'espère ne
pas donner d'idée tu vois en disant ça à
ces gens qui qui nous attaquent en
France sur notre sol mais au premier
attentat qui aura lieu dans un train tu
vas avoir des symposiums des
des des congrès des rapports des trucs
des machins et puis très vite bah les
trains seront sécurisés mais personne ne
croit que tout ça n'est pas
anticipable donc je pense que si ces
petites chosesl ne sont pas réglées de
façon un peu efficace et en fait tu vois
conformément à la lettre de la
Constitution française pardon de dire un
gros mot et de la loi française un
politique est là pour représenter
l'intérêt général
rien d'autre l'intérêt général si ça ne
se met pas à fonctionner comme ça je
pense que ces gens-là vont avoir
de grosses difficultés à gérer et ces
difficultés elles
seront des
difficultés populaire et il y a des
discours qui qui qui qui ont de plus en
plus d'écho dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens certains voient chez chez Le
Pen une solution à ça c'est pas cas
certains
voient chez Mélenchon une une une
révolte sincère ça ne me fait toujours
pas voter mais je suis tout à fait
convaincu que la révolte de d'un d'un
d'un gars comme Mélenchon et et tu vois
est sincère certains se sont détournés
c'est mon cas de de l'acte de voter
alors tout le machin de c'est ton devoir
citoyen et cetera
enfin sur quelqu'un comme moi ça n'a
aucune espèce de prise quand j'entendais
Vals je crois que c'était pendant les
régionales appeler un sursaut
républicain pour barrer la route à Le
Pen bah il y a un question il y a un
moment où il faut se poser la question
de savoir si la France ne mérite pas le
Pen c'est pas un engagement à à la
mettre au pouvoir ce que je suis en
train de faire c'est de te dire que il y
a tellement
d'attentisme chez nos concitoyens parce
qu'on est quand même un pays de gros cul
si on se parle un peu directement tu
vois on a on a cette espèce de capacité
à se à se révolter euh
comme ça d'un coup à résister à à
s'agglomérer autour d'une cause et
cetera mais personne n'a vraiment réussi
à modéliser ce qui nous déclenchait au
plan collectif et donc en
attendant enfin tu vois depuis montesque
il y a il y a un peu de temps qui est
qui qui est passé qui a passé tu vois
donc je je je crois qu'il serait assez
urgent de de se tourner vers des
mouvements citoyens le travail
d'Alexandre Jardin par par exemple chez
Bleu Blanc zèbre je te je t'engage à à
regarder ça de près parce que c'est ce
sont des gens qui d'abord sont issus de
la société
civile qui ne mettent pas des coups de
cllaxon médiatiques en disant regardez
on fait ça on est là pour faire la photo
et puis après on fout plus rien c'est
c'est des gens qui en région dans les
municipalités sur les terres de France
sont en train de fabriquer des vraies
solutions qui ne sont pas des solutions
politiques ils font de la politique ils
ne font que de la politique mais euh ils
ne sont pas eux des des hommes
politiques tu connais ma voix ouais
c'est un pense
euh je je je pense que ça ressemble de
de de très près à ces schémas qui
doivent être regardés euh pour ce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui et espérer que ça
deviendra euh ce que les concepteurs de
ma voix ou tout un tas d'autres
mouvements doivent avoir en tête quand
il quand il issent
mais il faut qu'on soit capable de
bouger en meut maintenant voilà si je
dois une stratégie à la Starcraft
résumer alors je sais pas ce qu'est
Starcraft en revanche c'est c'est un
écardage qui doit nous un jeu de
stratégie on on avance en M je connais
pas ça bon ok mais mais voilà on est des
Français nos dirigeants ne devraient pas
oublier qu'on est des Français parce que
français c'est pas il faudrait pas que
les Français noubl il faudrait pas que
les Français oublient soit français et
qu'il sont français mais moi je suis
d'accord avec toi je viens de te dire ça
tu vois enfin c'est-à-dire que je je je
suis tout à fait conscient qu'on est sur
un média totalement alternatif et
d'ailleurs le temps que tu m'offres
n'existe nulle part ailleurs on n'aime
pas tomber dans le simple et cours pour
nous tomber dans le simple et cours
c'est le passeport pour le slogan
idéologique pur et on aime prendre le
temps d'écouter les gens ouais ben c'est
c'est chouette bon David Koubi merci
salut à toi salut mon pote
[Musique]